fewer Zyliss winters wanted us to test
an iPhone 5s person iPhone 4 will do you
three better because today on Battle
Damage we've gathered up every major
iteration of the iPhone 4 an iPhone
battle royale from the iPhone 6 all the
way back to the one where they didn't
put a number in its name some of these
iPhones are so old you can't even
install kinder on them and some of them
are so new we've only installed tinder
on them it's time to swipe right for
battle damage tinder joke is that how it
works
first up the original iPhone this little
magic device changed it all next up
we've got the 3G which added a plastic
back and the ability to record video
then came the iPhone 4 with its straight
lines and all those antenna problems the
iPhone 5 doubled the RAM and got a
taller screen and finally the brand new
iPhone 6 some people say it bends in
your pocket could this flexibility help
as it's hurtled through the air let's
find out I have never used before
Eric just finished it last night what
this is the drop o matic more to go so
all you have to worry about Justin you
got a bubble level okay hit the green
button and what's the red button do
don't worry about the red button but do
not press it roll
was oddly satisfying stars one oh my
gosh it's fine fine scuffed up to a 3G
whatever line perfect for is also
totally fine I think the home button is
broken on this one five yes eliminated
this is the one I have haha I was
thought that was a toughest alright six
face down any words looks totally fine
yeah all right one down test the
survivors fifteen feet I'm like oddly
nervous right now
you're an apple guy oh he has a sweaty
roll action
oh I see some crackage did we lose the
one no the one is fine there's a big
dent on the top but the button still
works they built it right the first time
that's amazing 3g crack screen top bun
doesn't work it's dead out later for
looks flawless lord I mean it just looks
like gold like a tank that metal serie
on further inspection the back popped
off a little bit it still looks great
still usable but I think is gonna make
it not fare well for our third and final
test it's a series of trials the six is
brutally shattered the buttons do work
but you would definitely not leave this
so you're saying I should buy an iPhone
will you buy an iPhone 1 or an iPhone 4
all right I'm sold
don't you hate it when you spill coffee
on your phone here at Battle Damage to
take that concept to the extreme with
two gallons it's a fine cup of joe sure
is so that's when Peaks reference yeah
roll action
Oh God we're so bad boring
okay that's bull this wasn't some kind
of weird yeah we've gone a moat it's
still on the helmet it's like do you
want a powernow oh okay one is still
going in they just don't make them like
they used to so much caffeine little
bubbles coming out come on this is
insane
so we have determined at seven years of
iPhones guys go back roll it back
oh they're gone at one minute twenty one
seconds that was one of the most
unexpected results turning here first up
I've come one by one here on Battle
Damage link products fail we're not
satisfied just to let them lose now we
need to pulverize them with a fifty
pound safe safest Shane is ready alright
let's do it roll action
now hit the GoPro I think so Wow
shaming successful
alright that's it for this episode I
can't believe that the original iPhone
won crazy what's the worst thing that's
happened to your iPhone let us know in
the comments and then click right here
to see special behind-the-scenes
episode I'm so pumped by all the fun
destruction
I'm gonna smash money on to do it we got
an idea